[Music]
here's your money briefing for Friday
May 5th I'm J.R Whelan for the Wall
Street Journal
the next generation of workers will soon
be entering the workforce hoping to land
their first job according to a new poll
the class of 2023 has very clear
expectations of what they're looking for
in an employer wsj contributor and
founder of LaSalle Network Tom Gimbel
joins us to discuss the results of the
survey so Tom College seniors often line
up jobs before graduating but LaSalle's
most recent survey showed that 62
percent of recent grads had accepted a
job offer by the time they finished
College what does that tell us about the
job market for the class of 2023 we
surveyed about 2500 soon to be college
graduates and what it said to us when
the number was so high that there is
some pending fear over the economy they
don't want to wait and see what's out
there they interviewed aggressively and
when an offer came they took it now
simultaneously I think it's a much more
educated group of people due to social
media and transparency so I think they
also know what is available more than
any other graduating class as well so
the combination of the two what does it
tell us about the demand for college
graduates well what it says is about six
months ago it was almost a two to one
ratio one and a half to one ratio of the
number of jobs available versus workers
and now we're about a one to one but
what it says is that from an experienced
staff companies can't find the people
and so when that happens they're going
to revert to recent college graduates
they're going to sign them up early they
want to get the best of the best you
know Tom as much as nearly any 2023 grad
wants to land a job the employers really
need to attract the right candidates to
fill the spots what did students say
they're looking for in an employer they
want to know that there is Career
Development there's career progression
there's some sort of mentorship that
people actually at the end of the day
people care about me and I can hear it I
don't mind working 60 or 70 hours a week
if that's what the case may be and
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
and when companies learn how to map that
out and to sell the career path the
right way that's where people are saying
I want to work there you know but Career
Development isn't that important for
nearly anybody looking for an employer
it is and that's what they want but the
difference is most employers don't sell
it they think I have a job that I need
to get done today
and they talk about that and they talk
about the perks of the company oh we're
a best place to work or we get off early
on Fridays during the summer or whatever
it may be but they don't say in two
years you can be here in five years you
can be here here's the lateral movement
here's the traditional upward Mobility
here's an example of two or three people
who started in your role and where
they're at today right to me it's not
about what's possible it's about how you
message what's possible in past surveys
and in this year's survey College
seniors said that company culture is
important to them why does that keep
coming up I think it's where society's
going I'm 51 years old I know when my
dad was grinding it out in the 70s and
the 80s it was do what I tell you to do
and we'll see you for your bonus and
you'll know if you've got a good job and
that was it and even in the mid to late
90s when you came in and there wasn't
social media and the internet and email
was just happening there wasn't as much
communication amongst people if you
wanted talk to somebody whether to see
him in person or pick up a phone and now
it's email it's teams it's slack it's
instant messaging it's texting right so
I can text you and go hey JR did John
our boss just give you a raise did he
yell at you did he right instantaneously
we share these things so culture is so
important for people to know what
they're getting into coming out of the
pandemic we see a spotlight on some
benefits like remote work what are the
college seniors thoughts on a hybrid
work schedule or mixing and remote work
yeah four percent went fully remote the
majority went hybrid because if you ask
somebody if they want to when they
choose not to not have to come into an
office or get on a bus or a car right
they're going to say yes but what we're
seeing beyond the survey in actual
conversations is the kids coming out of
college are more than okay with going
into the office they want the right job
at the right company they want to move
to cities where there is healthy
environment they want to be around other
people period but other young people
they want to build friendships and going
into an office isn't something they
oppose in the class of 2023 is entering
a Workforce where employees of almost
all age groups are dealing with burnout
high levels of stress trying to achieve
a work-life balance and more companies
are recognizing that but our 2023 grads
prepared for that type of environment I
don't know if they're more prepared or
less prepared than other Generations but
one thing that we do have is there's
less of a stigma on mental illness and I
think that's really important that
people of all ages need therapy and now
more companies have therapy included
mental health included in their
traditional benefit package and through
covid with virtual therapy sessions that
was happening what I think is really key
is that leadership of a company has to
let people know it's okay so for example
in my organization I let the whole
company know that I've gone to therapy
on and off more on than off for the
better part of a decade like go to
therapy I think on the employees part
they've got to be conscious of it and
not schedule it for one o'clock in the
afternoon on Tuesday right and to do it
over a lunch to do it in the beginning
of the day at the end of the day and
those types of things but we all need a
little bit of space to do those things
and it's not surprising that this
generation is wanting to know that
mental health is something that
companies take seriously that was Wall
Street Journal contributor Tom gimble
and that's it for your money briefing
our producer is mohsin Ali our
supervising producer is Melanie Roy and
our executive producer is Chris zinsley
I'm your host J.R Whalen thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
thank you
[Music]